when I sold my business 28 years after I
started it I sold it for much too much
money according to industry standards
they paid me for my sales it was a great
company making great sales but then they
paid me double for my brand every minute
I spent building my brand paid me back
in dividends
you can't just work and work at building
your company without spending equal time
and attention at building your brand
it's what in the end is gonna get you
the most money in the equity for your
business I discovered the power of the
press by publishing a statistical survey
in the 1970s on the value of New York
City apartments I was a real estate
broker at the time we had 11 sales to
base my statistic on as the average
apartment sale it was preposterous but
of course thanks to the fact that I was
so young and too stupid to know any
better I published the report and it was
written up on the front page of the New
York Times real estate section which was
the Bible of the industry I realized
immediately it put me on the map I had
power my brand immediately people
started giving us listings my sales
people even started respecting me more
go figure
all it really was was a third-party
endorsement and a third-party
endorsement you can't pay for but when
they give it to you your name starts to
have meaning
think of branding as good old-fashioned
grandstanding think what do I have what
little thing do I have that I could blow
up and make really important in my
business I had to get in every article
that even addressed real estate so I
invented stuff almost like PT Barnum
when I found out that the co-op boards
in New York City were not welcoming dogs
in certain buildings and one board
actually said they're gonna interview
the dogs I invited a hundred dogs to
Central Park and taught them myself
online knees how to shake hands so they
could pass the co-op boards was it
preposterous of course it was but did
every single newspaper come out to cover
it with their camera crew you betcha
they do today nothing's really happening
in the print media it's a sidebar
everything that was in the print is now
online that's where the battle is won
and the good news is the little guys as
powerful starting out as the big guy
because it's a level playing field you
don't have to worry about the big guy
cornering you because the truth is the
little guy always has the corner on
creativity the big guy's got the corner
on money and money helps online but it's
not gonna build a brand as powerful as
great creative thinking is gonna do it
so today your presence online is
everything and you could do it an inch
at a time but you better be working on
it every single day if you want to build
a powerful bread
you